you know i i will say this though when
you do lose weight i think those
compliments do feel good because of how
hard you work to get to that point right
but when somebody
starts to gain weight back a little bit
they gain a little weight or something
like that i do understand because i see
a lot of posts and how it affects them
and they'll see like certain friends of
mine they'll delete these comments
because it makes them feel bad because
now you're starting to like what was the
point you're the same person that
complimented them the weight loss but
now that they gain some weight they go
look at you you're getting fat again
what is the point of that [ __ ] also in
five four three two
one cheers cheers
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast i am
your host david soh with the vine glass
of vino and i got my clothes today ed
park
with a little bit of vodka that's the
only alcohol you drink
yeah i i got into just non-sugary just
clear drinks uh especially when i got
into keto
i learned that vodka was alcohol you can
actually drink cheetos yeah so you're
not doing keto anymore i'm not actually
i've gained like 15 pounds it's good it
well says a little bit about how i feel
about myself i actually feel chubby
really yeah you look great i know
i hear that i hear that that's part of
my
weird mental because i've been 140 145
for the past three years now yeah and
then to be i'm one like 160 now i feel a
little chubby it was crazy you don't
look like you're 100 but you've always
been thicker i had like your chest is
really big you have a big back yeah yeah
yeah yeah i mean like i don't have to do
leg day you know because you look the
same size as my brother but my brother's
145. but you guys look similar in size
yeah cause i wouldn't guess that you're
that you're 160 at all that's actually
kind of shocking to me yeah uh because
well that's another thing i'm like
eating a lot of korean pear
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] you know i
haven't had it in years i'm like yeah
i'm gonna eat this but it's still too
much sugar i think that's what's
contributing to it but then i gotta be
more comfortable in my skin be like this
is a normal weight 160. yeah yeah what
made you uh uh quit uh keto
um well
uh when we started doing like kickboxing
whatever like i was trying to get more
fit right and have more strength but
you [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of me
because i had no gas yeah on keto like i
was like my [ __ ] knees felt like
newborn deer like they were just shaking
and i had no balance yeah i had no
energy to do
like a [ __ ] 20 minute workout you
know and i was realizing ah [ __ ] like
being lethargic and keto go really well
because you can do nothing and burn fat
yeah
i was like oh my god i'm dying but when
you start working out you're like [ __ ]
like there's double time no energy yeah
so i was like [ __ ] if i actually want to
work out okay gotta introduce some carbs
but i'm eating too much candy and [ __ ]
like too much chocolate on the side
too much [ __ ] that's so funny um but
you see them but you moderate your food
pretty well though i tried to i mean i
can still eat like a big boy oh
yeah like
every time i go to like panda express i
can kill that entire one serving that
they give you know what's crazy too you
know with the you know the topic about
when we talk about weight loss
so i was in hawaii for a week right
eating whatever the [ __ ] i wanted yeah
just
a savage if there was food i was going
to eat it it didn't matter i only i
didn't eat when i was hungry i ate
because i wanted to because you could
yeah that's it
right because the options are so many
there's a musubi right there yeah no
you're just going to leave it exactly we
would eat and my you know my brother
went to my my best friend gabba was
there
uh abe was there and we were just having
a good time i gained like eight pounds
in a matter of like what seven days
easy [ __ ] and that's decent
i'll tell you this though i didn't feel
good yeah i felt [ __ ] terrible i um
had heartburn
uh woke up full i woke up feeling like
[ __ ] every day uh it's probably because
like you're all swollen from eating and
you're getting that [ __ ] sleep apnea
yeah it's just all this all this [ __ ]
just compounds you know when i look back
at how big i was right and when that
discomfort was so [ __ ] normal like we
made this joke it's like dude i didn't
know you're not supposed to diarrhea
every day
you know yeah
it's just that's how people poop
but you get so used to being
uncomfortable that that uncomfortable
healthy lethargic feeling that you get
from being so out of shape and being
really overweight becomes your norm and
i didn't know that it was my norm until
i lost the weight and then now that
during pandemic i've gained like i see i
was like pre-pandemic i was like maybe
205 pounds i'm like 224 right now right
so i gained like 19 pounds i feel it um
definitely a lot more lethargic
uh i wore a jacket yesterday because
it's getting a little cold i thought it
could fit it
that's not fit
damn jackets are usually supposed to be
like that big comfy yeah because i
remember i had this obey jacket it's
like a puffer jacket it's my winter
jacket and i put it on and usually it
has a little space in it yeah this [ __ ]
i look like a grenade
bro
[ __ ] this shit's about to just
burst i'm like holy [ __ ] this [ __ ]
doesn't fit and it's true though i i
think because we're so used to being big
our whole lives
i don't really think about how much it
it [ __ ] with our self-esteem a lot
right and um
it's one of those things that i think i
i offset my
me feeling not great about myself for
being a fatter guy with my humor i was
always allowed to be funny and you know
we're such goofy guys yeah yeah i mean
and that's one of the things i i like to
carry with me um now that i'm this way
like i'll look at i was just looking at
my old fat photos because i was feeling
fat
i know what'll make me feel better if i
look at my old fat photos yeah let me
show you what really fat looks like i'm
not that anymore yeah but yeah for sure
like i carry
some of those insecurities with me even
though i'm like way beyond that now but
then um i'll feel a certain way when
someone
you know sees oh it's like oh you look
like you're filling in now like what
but for them it's a compliment yeah it's
a compliment because actually everyone
was saying i was i looked too god like
scrawny yeah like that's when it hit a
different bone like okay i like when
people call me skinny but if you call me
scrawny
[ __ ] you dude but this is the odd thing
too and i i hear this a lot and i it's
funny because i read this quote
uh from jonah hill and jonah hill was
like don't mention
anything about my weight
don't say that i lost weight because i
look better when i'm skinny and don't
mention that when i'm fat just don't
[ __ ] talk about my weight yeah it
doesn't make me feel good either or
right just leave it alone
because he can only be in control of
what is
right where he's at well people always
have to make a comment about somebody's
weight and i i wonder what that is right
because i get it yeah
i think it all the time yeah you know
when i see some of these youtubers i
haven't seen in a while and they [ __ ]
explode like they're huge in my mind i'm
like holy [ __ ] but i don't say it out
loud i don't write it in comments you
don't need to write like my i just want
to ask when people write that out in
public what is your objective
is it
there is an objective when we do when we
have action things right is it to make
this person feel bad that they gain
weight and some people are like well i
just want to know that i care and i want
them to be healthier that's not what it
is you wrote that comment so people can
thumbs up your [ __ ] thing and say oh
i also noticed this person got too
skinny or too fat that's what you're
looking for but you're not doing it
because you care about that person yeah
the object the objective of what you're
doing is to glorify yourself and your
stupid [ __ ] unnecessary comment
like oh i know what i'm doing i'm a i'm
a health freak i i do diets too it's not
even that's the fattest [ __ ] people
that write that [ __ ]
literally the fattest [ __ ] people on
earth i call that fat splaining yeah
yo when when i lost all that weight
trust me there's so many people still
giving me unsolicited advice about
losing weight like bro i'm skinnier than
you now yeah don't [ __ ] tell me how
to lose weight like be [ __ ] quiet
also too like
that that's why i do understand when
people get annoyed when people make
weight comments right and i read it all
the time but it's just it's kind of like
it just doesn't matter to me maybe it's
because you know i've done stand-up and
stuff so getting boot off stage is one
of the worst feelings you could ever
feel having somebody talk to me tell me
that i'm fat when i know i'm fat yeah
it's like telling me the [ __ ] sky is
blue right and that's the whole thing
like i [ __ ] know yeah i know you
don't gotta like mention it to me right
but there's another end of the spectrum
too like there was a time when i didn't
know when i was yeah i know
yeah because
i because at the same time the other
spectrum being that people are are too
polite and they don't mention it right
and actually in your head you don't even
know how fat you're getting yeah yeah
yeah
but that's hilarious because there was
actually a time
you actually weighed less than me yeah
and you had to sit we sat down for lunch
and you'd be like hey man
you fat bro
like you're telling me that i had to do
something you're like you're like 240
pounds yeah that was [ __ ] huge yeah yeah
but there's another funny story so um
uh
dumb and zoe came to seattle right and i
went to the show and um i went backstage
to see them
and they hadn't seen me for a couple
years and i had just lost all this
weight
and if you don't know this about dom
he's the most nicest encouraging person
you'll ever meet like he will hype you
up like so much he's the opposite of me
he made me feel so good about myself
because he's like yo i've been i've seen
your progress
and then uh zoe walks into the room he
goes holy [ __ ] is that head you used
to be so [ __ ] fat
[Laughter]
and
you know i i wasn't trying to say that
but damn
that's [ __ ] funny dude zoe's the best
dude yeah
he's the most talented dj yeah he's so
[ __ ] good dude that's hella funny but
you know you would get all these
comments about yo i'm
you know i i will say this though when
you do lose weight i think those
compliments do feel good because of how
hard you work to get to that point right
but when somebody
starts to gain weight back a little bit
they gain a little weight or something
like that i do understand because i see
a lot of posts and how it affects them
and they'll see like certain friends of
mine they'll delete these comments
because it makes them feel bad because
now you're starting to like what was the
point you're the same person that
complimented them the weight loss but
now that they gain some weight they go
oh look at you you're getting fat again
what is the point of that [ __ ] also too
when i click into your profile you're
the most disgusting [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my life shut the [ __ ] up leave these
people alone yeah like and for me i
always have to go to bat and defend
these people and tell these people to
shut the [ __ ] up because i know how much
it affects them because they tell me
just be the right person right yeah like
when bart tells me then i'd be like yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah do something about that
yeah they're like well i'm trying to
help you who are you in my life to go
ahead and say that [ __ ] yeah you're
nobody in my life if you [ __ ] die
tomorrow i wouldn't shed a tear so leave
those things where you're saying you're
trying to help me
you'll never help that's a weird
conundrum because like what if someone
said that to you too yeah yeah you're
looking a little chubby like every day i
go into your dms i'm like bro i can't
believe you're how do you breathe you
fat [ __ ] when you lay down doesn't your
lungs collapse with [ __ ] twinkies and
lard you fat piece of [ __ ] i care about
you
i'm only saying this because i care
because i care cause i [ __ ] love you
but then why do i feel so terrible when
you say it it's it's a weird thing right
and that was stuff that i had to
navigate when i was younger like i see
it all the time right so there was one
comment though that had me [ __ ] dying
only because of how much it affected me
and i was telling tim about this but we
did a video together and somebody writes
like hey
you know david looks like he's gaining
some weight i'm really concerned like
how are things going on in his life can
you ask him i read that [ __ ] and i was
like
[Music]
that [ __ ] hurt a little bit
it sounded a little it's not too real
you know
yeah wait do i even know you because
this person [ __ ] cares too much does
she hurt my feelings bad it's like am i
gaining that much weight am i getting
like 19 pounds or so yeah but for me too
once again it's all activity-based like
if i want to lose weight i'm going to
lose it again but
all these celebrities too they get
scrutinized so much it doesn't matter
you can't [ __ ] win because we could
talk about adele you know adele no
matter what she does and we know i
mentioned this about lizzo 2 or any of
these like larger female artists because
women get the most [ __ ] when it comes to
weight loss how they look how they look
it's it's basically
it's what their value is based on so
[ __ ] much because a guy can be fat
and funny and he's fine but if a girl is
fat and funny he's like oh she's not
cute the weirdest thing too is like
let's say liz'll lose a [ __ ] ton of
weight there's going to be some haters
like oh i only jacked off to you because
you're big
no adele she got a bunch of [ __ ] because
she lost a lot of weight and she was
doing it for her personal reasons
because like bigger you know white women
were like you represented me yeah who
the [ __ ] said that that was her
responsibility
right who the [ __ ] said uh you were the
big confident girl whatever well now
she's the skinny confident girl and the
thing that i always see the most and
once again this is coming from somebody
who's still overweight that this this
[ __ ] always cracks me up is when
somebody who is unhealthy
they always use this example they go
well just because you're skinny doesn't
mean that you're healthy a hundred
percent sure however when you're
morbidly obese
you're not healthy there's no there's no
such thing of [ __ ] being big and
healthy yeah like the morbidly obese and
healthy right like you're you're a
hundred pounds overweight and you're
still like i still work out it doesn't
mean that you're healthy and i'm coming
from a point where i had to get i had i
got blood work done i had all this stuff
done i had the whole uh body mass index
right scanner thing done
i did all that [ __ ] i know where i was
at physically and it wasn't good you
know so i don't need you to tell me that
i'm healthy it's the fat acceptance
logic yeah right where it it just goes
on the oh let's go anti the fat shaming
but then
you can't like do opposite day on some
of the fact-based criticisms yeah right
like okay i can understand like beauty
being subjective right so big girl being
yeah 100 agree yeah agreed right beauty
in the eyelid beholder
but then be like no she's healthy or
they're healthy
she's like no yeah i'm sorry no it's
it's a simple matter of this it's like
like i kind of rash back to what i was
saying before if you feel like somebody
who is not healthy that they're fat and
you feel that way how about you shut the
[ __ ] up and keep it to yourself no
that's the big thing yeah you don't know
these people personally where you can
affect their life where you can make
them in your mind make them change for a
for the better in terms of health
shut the [ __ ] up don't talk about them
i'll tell you though um i did a little q
a while i was losing all that weight so
i had finally hit my hundred pound loss
like goal
and then i did a q a and they were like
what motivated you to work out i was
like resentment
i thought about all those [ __ ]
that made fun of me for being fat and i
was like i'll [ __ ] show you [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah that was part of the big
it's like let's say like i i when i was
doing my fasts like really hard
um a
i would think about like
people giving me [ __ ] for being fat
but b i would also like grab my tit tell
my body look there's so much energy
right here
this fat right here this is reserved i
grabbed my stomach i'll grab the back of
my back right here be like this is
energy
eat this
that's [ __ ] funny but it's crazy how
much that stuff starts to affect your
psyche right yeah you just never know we
either mask it with humor or we do
something else with it
and
it's just a weird place to be in like
mentally it developed our great
personalities yeah
you know when i finally lost that weight
it's like hey now i have great
personality and a rocking body
[Laughter]
it's hard though losing weight you know
um
no it's the addiction part of it right
there's a mental state of mind like when
you're saying all these people telling
you you're fat and all these things like
where you gotta go to the doctor
you know and talk to a guy who's gonna
like let you know bro you're morbidly
obese yeah right that's someone like you
would listen to right not all the
noise and all the comments and all that
[ __ ] in the air but it's like you
you yourself have to look yourself in
the mirror and be like this ain't right
it's funny too i i i read this comment
where you know i mentioned this and they
go well somebody david is as a person
who was really overweight you should
understand you were active when you were
bigger like were you considered
unhealthy even though you could do all
the stuff that all these you know
physically fit people could do i was
like
my knees are [ __ ] up
i lost all the cartilage in my [ __ ]
knees yeah because of me playing
basketball at that weight yeah so no
you're wrong i i was suffering
consistently back pain lower back pain
knee pain joint pain it was all [ __ ] i
had heartburn every [ __ ] night i just
thought it was normal yeah i had acid
reflux i would just sit and all of a
sudden acid with gurgle out of my throat
and i'm just like it's a monday
oh it's because you know sunday cheat
day even though every day is cheating
exactly you know like i said we would
consistently just normalize this pain
all the time so i don't need people to
tell me that i should feel good about
being fat and i'm still a good person i
never said that i was a bad person
because i was fat i'm telling you i
didn't feel
good and once again if you're big and
you like being big give a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] you want like i said my opinion in
space about how you what you do with
your body doesn't [ __ ] matter and i
will never write a comment on your page
in your personal life and tell you that
you're fat overweight or disgusting
because number one none of my business
number two i don't care yeah right i
mind my own business when it comes to
that stuff so at the end of the day when
i when i make comments about how i felt
for somebody to come and insert their
opinion about how i should feel about my
weight and tell me that oh you were
still an awesome person i never [ __ ]
said i wasn't why the [ __ ] do you keep
like mixing those two things together
and that's that's one of the problems
like a you're never gonna give them that
affirmation because there are these
other big people looking at a big
influencer and be like hey i'm fine
right when they're not gonna expect to
be like no
yeah
right and like because you know you're
not [ __ ] liars yeah right but the
other part too is is like when um
we don't really
like we i was saying earlier like we
don't
see it for ourselves as being fat yeah
until we have to get our own reality
check right yeah
yeah that's the that's the the weird
part right when the moment that you
realize that you don't that you're not
healthy and then you have to make this
change it was it was very difficult i
just remember the
just people i just remember how
short-tempered i was when i was trying
to withdraw from all the foods that i
was addicted to yeah like an excessive
amount of fat an excessive amount of
carbs and if i didn't have it i would
throw a tantrum
like a baby
like and i think that was the part that
bothered me the most is that i couldn't
control my urge just not to eat an
excessive amount of sugars and
carbohydrates and like an excessive
amount because i still eat what i want
now i just do it in moderation and i'm a
lot better with it so like for example i
was in hawaii i came back i was 228
pounds it's been about four days i'm
back down to 240
224 okay so and that's just all bloat
that's all every all this other [ __ ] and
i'm back to exercising and i still and i
feel better now well
it's still hard because i got so
addicted to eating these foods even when
it made me feel bad i wanted to eat more
of it it is a literal [ __ ] addiction
for you to do something that you know is
killing you but it still makes you feel
good even though you feel bad what kind
of [ __ ] is that
god i can't think about the times about
like i get embarrassed when i think of
all those angry moments over food
i got through a massive [ __ ] tantrum
at church once right
because so they have you know after and
then korean church after service there's
uh yeah for everyone right um it's
usually always korean food but then um
there is another food line run by
because like i said in tacoma there's a
lot of army vets that go to korean
churches with their korean wives right
and they serve the american food like
you know hamburgers hot dogs and that
stuff so one time i was in line
and there was a girl in front of me and
i was the last person in line right
there was two hot dogs left
and she bought both hot dogs even though
there's us two left in the line i was
like there's enough for both of us she
got two hot dogs and i was so angry i
went back
and i grabbed the chair and i threw it
across the room my friends are eating
their hot dogs like what the [ __ ] is
your problem that is the fattest [ __ ]
thing i've ever heard in my life
i was so that [ __ ] is hilarious and
think about that kind of hangry though i
think you look at her you're like hey
can i get your number
i like your style
because i like the way you move
if i was you i also would have got two
hot dogs
i threw a massive tantrum
but uh speaking of the other thing you
were talking about um i don't think
people realize that fat david and skinny
david is still the same [ __ ] person
yeah this one's gonna live longer yeah
exactly like i sometimes feel like
people look at me as two different
people now because um there was that guy
they knew that was being fat and now i'm
this but i'm like
yeah i'm still the same edward right but
at the same time i would also get this
sense of like this identity crisis like
i stopped wanting to be known as that
guy who lost 100 pounds
there was something about it that made
me be like let me distance myself from
weight loss now yeah just be me
right because people always want to be
like that's the guy that does keto i'm
the keto guy or that's the weight loss
guy or whatever and
then what happens
like hundreds of people get so many dms
asking me how to lose weight yeah right
and like he's just like
i don't know i suffered and i googled
yeah you know but okay there's another
funny story so
do you know what uh subtle asian traits
is
it's a facebook group
millions of people in it it's about this
asian culture you know okay like uh you
know black people have black people
twitter yeah like things are on facebook
okay it's called subtle asian traits
well there was an offshoot of that group
called subtle asian dating
right so i jumped into that too right
um and it's hilarious memes about asian
people dating but people also auction
themselves they have photos of
themselves and they sell their pros and
cons and introduce themselves it's kind
of like dating on facebook yeah right
um
so i'm out there in the sticks running
the grocery store i ain't got nothing to
do i have a six pack and i'm not
impressing these methods
yeah
so
i go ahead and i post myself into that
spot it goes [ __ ] viral i get like 11
000 likes on that [ __ ] right
but all of my dms
dudes asking me how i lost weight that's
hella funny dude how do you get any
girls like hitting me up for anything
that's so funny it was all these other
fat asian dudes like chung how do you do
it
this [ __ ] group is [ __ ] yeah i
could get a single girl
that group is literally all faced that's
what you found out it's all guys around
guys like thirsting and then like i now
i know all the secrets
that's [ __ ] you know what the thing
is too guys like
just as a heads up right
you losing weight
it's not going to help you get a girl
you're just going to be the same person
with low self-esteem has a terrible
image of yourself because you're
tackling the wrong issues why do you
feel the way that you do
yeah it probably does have to stem from
your self-esteem because of your weight
but then there's so much to work on
after that because there's baggage with
that yeah i mean i mean
part of our great we've been friends for
like 10 years now yeah long time like
we were two big guys full of confidence
we knew who we were yeah we knew who we
were yeah and if you see guys who
carry insecurity with them
when like they lose weight you you can
get hookups for sure yeah right but damn
it like if you don't work anything out
about who you are and your personality
and your insecurities and all that
um long-lasting relationships
yeah good luck
it can happen it can happen it's hard
they think the weight loss thing is is
like a cure for their personality and
it's not it's not there's so much things
you have to worry about it's the same
thing with those guys who or girls
who try to mask their insecurities or
their inadequacies that they have with
their personality traits with money
right oh you thought i was a loser in
high school well guess what i got this
high six figure paying job now that's
funny now you're a loser with money yeah
it's like you know does that make you
any more approachable exactly you're
still the [ __ ] dweeb that nobody
wants to talk to because you're socially
awkward as [ __ ]
you're you being broke had nothing to do
with the fact that people didn't want to
be around you and everything to do the
fact that you're [ __ ] weird as [ __ ]
you don't know how to talk to people and
you're awkward as hell right you focused
on the wrong things you thought money
was going to fix it you thought that the
weight loss was going to fix you know
your social inadequacies it has nothing
to do with any of that stuff yeah if
you're a dope person people will
gravitate towards that [ __ ] all the time
when they say work on yourself i i
really do believe too um
a lot of the reasons why people fail to
lose weight is because they're kind of
the weight is like the tertiary issue
there's things there's a reason why that
you're overweight there's a reason why
that you you cope with a lot of your
terrible emotions with food oh yeah i
mean one of the biggest factors to get
me to start losing weight um before
seeing the doctors or anything was
therapy why am i fat
why do i not think i should be skinny
why do i not why why am i depriving
myself of a long life
right why am i allowing myself to die in
my 40s or 50s yeah right like i'm asking
because
i mean i'm smoking jewels now yeah
e-cigarettes but i was a heavy smoker a
pack or two a day
and
fat as [ __ ] like there was a lot of
factors in these things that
with my behavior and my habits that i
wasn't even addressing like why am i
this big to begin with yeah that's the
first thing you have to tackle before
you like
give yourself permission allow yourself
now to go through the hardness you can
call it suffering you can call it
[ __ ] self-abuse or whatever i don't
give a [ __ ] but it's what it takes to
lose weight you just have to do a
calorie deficit you know and and and i
say this to the people the most who
consistently talk about their weight and
they always verbally have to say i don't
care that i'm fat i don't care that i'm
fat
you clearly do because you've said it so
many times and i say that because i know
what it feels like because i was there
too it always did bother me not so much
to what what people would say about me
but it bothered me that i just didn't
feel good yeah i would do nothing about
it and i'd always say and i would always
throw it off with jokes or whatever but
at the end of the day i have to live
with my choices nobody's gonna help me
get healthier i just have to do it and
if i keep on stacking it with excuses of
well there are big people who are who
are large like look at sumo wrestlers
they're athletes
doesn't mean they're not going to die in
like [ __ ]
like a guy [ __ ] yeah you know people
always use that sumo wrestler thing like
i'm supposed to be proud of it they go
dude david but sumo wrestlers are
athletes yeah they're fat [ __ ]
athletes
they're [ __ ] they're they're not
healthy they're not in great position
yeah they're not healthy yeah they're
actually strong yes like like big fat
people are strong too like the reason
why my legs are so big is cause i was
carrying a hundred pounds like every day
for years yeah right but yeah there's
strength that comes with being big but
that's that's not healthy at all yeah
and it's always like i said too it's
always the guy that says like hey let me
give you an example of this guy who did
triathlons and he's morbidly obese cool
are you yeah one in a billion it's like
are you though
are you the guy that's a triathlete
that's swimming in a [ __ ] salt in an
ocean popping out on a bike biking for
30 miles and then coming out perfectly
fine no you're the guy that's sitting
there talking about the guy that's doing
that it's not feeling good about
yourself i'm talking about health-wise
and also mentally and also could they
even do a [ __ ] triathlon yeah
don't don't speak for that guy that guy
can speak for himself he has the body of
work to show what
that he's healthy and he has the metrics
for it and do those people say if i can
do it you can do it too i think those
people know that they're one in a
billion yeah right like because even for
me like
the reason why i stopped giving weight
loss advice is because i swear to god 99
of people i've given advice to haven't
lost weight
yeah right and and it's like well they
they want a quick solution yeah and it's
just not gonna happen so when i tell
them my method which is absolutely nuts
don't do what i did yeah that's what i
had to realize
that i did very extreme binary um
tactics to have to lose weight
although it was scientifically correct i
went through heart a lot of hardness
right and i had to realize not everyone
can do it a lot of people will look at
it as suffering wow i
in my suffering i was grabbing my tits
saying there's enough fat here to live
off of now also everyone's included from
humanity right
yeah it's not like i i didn't have
anyone to support me or help me at all i
had to do it on my own and i had that
attitude now like
i can't help you because hey i'm super
[ __ ] far away but this is on your own
discipline this is your own
accountability
like no one was there to support me to
do anything yeah any of it at all yeah i
had to do it on my because i needed my
own self realization i had to be real
with myself i'll tell you this easy come
easy go is what always happens um i know
you are only two out of maybe i say like
definitely over 10 people who've done
keto that was successful right right and
you're the only one that i know that did
keto that stayed successful yeah the
only one oh so well i feel good about
myself all right so um other people who
have done keto yeah they kind of
lost the weight and they kept they kept
they kept summited some of it off
but they blew right the [ __ ] back up
right after because easy come easy go
because it's a very hard lifestyle to
keep up yeah and once again you did the
homework and you found the reason to why
you were so addicted to being overweight
and unhealthy in the first place so it
kind of puts you in a good good space to
be at right a lot of everybody else if
they don't find the reason why they're
always going to go back to the thing
that's the easiest which is to eat again
this podcast is brought to you by better
help if you haven't focused on your
mental health this year now is the time
to start listen we've all been cooped up
tense and honestly we know the
importance of our mental health so let's
stop pushing our thoughts and emotions
aside and start feeling again my friends
listen if you haven't tried therapy and
you want to give it a go give better
help a try it'll assess your needs and
match you with your own license
professional therapist and you don't
have to sit in an uncomfortable waiting
room and you can message your counselor
at any time while setting up weekly
video or phone sessions it's super
convenient and more importantly allows
you to be in your own safe and
comfortable environment listen i've used
betterhelp and it was honestly an
amazing experience and i still use and
talk to my counselor till this day so
give it a try and you have nothing to
lose so special offer for genius brain
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
genius so visit betterhelp.com
genius and get that 10 off and work on
that mental health baby
and because those are the moments of
happiness and when you kind of like
identify yourself with like for your
example oh i'm the keto guy that joy
goes away yeah and you're just left with
this
it was like okay i'm ed the guy who lost
weight after that [ __ ] goes away what
are you you just ed yeah the theory of
desire going back to squid game yeah go
back to school yeah now you're just ed
yeah so what now people stop mentioning
oh you're the guy that lost weight
because now they're just like oh you're
just fit ed yeah so
that attachment of being the guy who
lost 100 pounds has has gone away now
now you have to be left with these
choices who are you now yeah like i'm
not going around being like hey i used
to weigh like 100 pounds right no i
don't want you know that that doesn't
define me either like
like you were saying like being fat is
not your identity yeah right and but if
you make it your identity then that's
what you live for yeah right and so when
you lose that part then what you got to
fill that up with something else now i'm
the fit you know version of me and what
now everyone has to know that no you're
actually your identity is way more than
your condition yeah right because
yeah obesity is a condition condition
means it it can change yeah also too
even when you lose weight there'll be
times where you're going to gain 10
pounds you're going to lose 10 pounds
you'll gain 20 lose another 15. your
body's going to fluctuate all the time
and you have to be okay with that you
have to understand too you can't beat
yourself up every time on this
what your scale says about you because
you're conflating your weight with the
value of yourself as a person and that's
the hardest thing to get around with
some of these kids it's just they're
like oh my god i gained weight i gained
so much weight it's like yeah you did
you'll just lose it again i'm okay when
people mention that stuff because
they're just kind of talking that's fine
yeah when i see the affect
the value of themselves
that's when i get a little bit concerned
and once again too it's probably not
it's their fault and not their fault at
the same time because of what other
people say about them constantly it's
those [ __ ] instagram comments it's
those youtube comments is those people
around your circle talking [ __ ] about
you because of your weight and people
need to really cut that [ __ ] out and
that's why we have these extremes that
people come out we have people who are
on the big girl movement because they're
so sick of people telling them that
they're not beautiful that they're not
worthy because they don't look a certain
way and that's why people start to
identify who they are with their weight
now because they're fighting back
against all this other stupid [ __ ]
and it goes the opposite way around with
those people who are so buff all they do
is talk about how buff they are
all the time
yeah you know what i mean their identity
is their identity linked to like how
they look
and that doesn't define you guys like
even when um like i'm growing up in
church everyone knew me as the worship
leader guy right and i didn't like that
i i am so much more than a guy who leads
worship every sunday right then i'm the
guy that does it hi yeah
you mentioned that
i'm not just a worship leader i do it in
a [ __ ] different time zone
in another universe bro
i praise god and i see him literally a
hilarious thing too just tie it in i
smoke weed every day while i lost 100
pounds
so to take off that sigma as as uh ed
the pothead yeah i wasn't [ __ ] lazy
and laying around or you know doing
nothing i i lost 100 pounds smoking weed
i was high the whole time that's
hilarious
don't tell me i can't praise the lord
if i could control my munchies i could
praise the lord high as [ __ ] yeah
and you know what
depriving myself from the munchies was
part of my discipline tactic ah yeah
like so
um yeah okay i can fast i can do
whatever but what if i'm high and i have
the munchies really hard can i still not
eat yeah and i proved myself to that and
i saw the results and i lost weight and
then i had a different outlook on what
marijuana was doing for me you know i
don't smoke as much as i used to
you know but
yeah like uh there's
so many things like embarrass that you
can break because of the stigma
of what you think about it like
especially the stigma of people too
afraid to lose weight believe it or not
are people afraid to lose weight yeah
but you know and that's a big hump that
uh for some people to have to get over
because they're not really looking
themselves in the mirror they're too
ashamed to look in the mirror i had uh i
was doing instagram live and i was
talking to this girl
and she's super funny and it originally
started out with um relationship advice
and i kept talking to her and we could
continue this conversation and then she
mentioned something about her way she
goes i have a dope ass personality i'm
fat i know it and i don't really care
and i was like well hold on for a second
i never asked you about your weight
so why did you feel like it was
important for you to bring that up and
she goes i just feel like people expect
me to look a certain way and that i just
want to go ahead and fight against it
and i was like well let me ask you
something do you say that because of are
you trying to fight back because of how
people make you feel or is that because
of how you actually feel about yourself
yeah she got really quiet she started
tearing up yeah dude
she brought up defense mechanisms before
anyone went on the offense yeah she goes
i'm going to strike you before you
strike me right because i wasn't even
thinking about that first of all we're
on facetime i don't know what your body
is like but it's about how she feels
about herself and i was telling her hey
if you want to lose weight at the end of
the day you can only do it if you do it
for yourself it always has to be for
yourself that goes in anything that you
do in life whether it's a career path or
relationships or anything else right you
can't do stuff based on somebody else's
agenda if it's important for you enough
to bring it up in this conversation when
nobody mentioned it it's something that
bothers you and you can't do it because
people are keep calling you fat or
they're making you know or your parents
asian parents do a great job of talking
about your weight
do it because you want to do it and i
guarantee you if it makes you happy then
you should stick to it if you're happy
being a big girl or a big boy
then you shouldn't have to go ahead and
put it on a microphone 24 7. just be
happy in your existence yeah
it's so important not to do it because
other people said so yeah if you're
trying to impress somebody else
that's a loser lost cause you'll fail
every [ __ ] time or even if you do
succeed you'll bounce right back to your
old habits because once that demon's
gone you beat that [ __ ] demon what
are you left with oh yeah dude i would
wake up in the middle of the night
because my mom's praying for me
she has my hand
and on my belly praying to god that i
need to lose weight you know
as if god's gonna be like oh [ __ ] my bad
so guess what happened when i when i
lost all that weight i had a six-pack
and i was showing my mom look on my i
got a six-pack you know i'm trying to
help her because of when she's praying
on my [ __ ] belly yeah what'd she say
you're too skinny
trust me what other people have to say
at the end of the day
doesn't [ __ ] matter
right it's on you it's on your standards
it's on your own will it's on you you'll
never be your goals compared to other
people's stances you'll never be smart
enough you'll never be pretty enough
you'll never be
successful enough you'll never have
enough money it doesn't [ __ ] matter
man i think that's one of the biggest
reasons why i love going to hawaii
because nobody mentions any of this
i'm a model
[Laughter]
i'm a standard body out there i'm the
prototype hawaiian baby
you know i'm just a little pale
when i go out there
you know just once again to give love
and credit to people in hawaii like they
always do
none of my friends there they never talk
about wealth yeah they never talk about
what i'm wearing what i have
um what i'm driving none of that [ __ ]
they go what do you want to
eat hey let's go to a beach today yeah
you know we hang out we joke around we
talk about [ __ ] but they never ever
mention about wealth what we have houses
that we want to buy the next career move
we don't say any of this [ __ ] they
always exist in the now and they
appreciate what they have right in front
of them ain't no squid games in hawaii
there's no squid game in hawaii dude
they go yeah hey here's the money
they're like
all right and they'll probably walk out
that'd be a funny parody like hawaiian
games they're just like hey get me to a
beach bro and everybody just hits the no
i'm out button yeah
you know there are people in hawaii
their their economic situation sucks
right there are people in hawaii right
now if you guys don't know people who
who have grown up there their whole
lives are being displaced because they
can't afford housing out there yeah
because it's so [ __ ] expensive and i
know this right now because
i'm looking to rent rent a place out
there because i'm planning to open up a
business right i want to rent a spot
dude the rent out there is like la
prices but they have the shittiest pay
out there yeah you know so now like when
i open up this business i want to make
geared towards locals they're going to
get the kamae in a discount if you don't
know what kama aina is like come on is
like local discount yeah right and we
want to for me because i deal with like
i'm dealing dealing with a lot of like
community outreach and marketing i want
to donate if we do really well and
successful donate our drinks um
our time do a lot of charity work out
there too because people don't
understand that these people have to
work their ass off sometimes most of the
times actually work two jobs just to
keep their just to stay in their house
yeah
all these outsiders are coming in buying
up all the real estate yeah you know
like that whole [ __ ] deal with uh
mark zuckerberg yeah all those acres of
land and all that what the [ __ ] yeah
they're literal displacement yeah like
what's the point zuckerberg why the [ __ ]
would you buy all that [ __ ] land yeah
like what's the point dude you [ __ ]
weirdo [ __ ]
yeah what use does he have to do for
your [ __ ] robot you don't need any of
that you're [ __ ] [ __ ] chinese dude
[ __ ] chinese sucks bro i don't care
what you say you know when like you know
facebook crashed recently too [ __ ] yeah
i didn't know i was in
yeah hawaii could give a [ __ ] less yeah
i was chilling out there and then um i
guess when it came back on i didn't know
it came back on because i wasn't looking
at my phone yeah um
and people are like dude everybody's
freaking out because instagram was gone
and now it's back and facebook lost
millions and millions of dollars and it
was i forgot it was like for a few hours
yeah it was i don't know how many hours
it was but it wasn't a whole day and it
was a few hours everybody was freaking
the [ __ ] out which kind of blew my mind
a little bit says a lot it says a lot
about our society yeah
i'm talking about people who don't use
this for a living and even if you did
use facebook and instagram for a living
three four hours did nothing to you yeah
like personally it did a lot to the
company because of ad revenue and
everything else but to you personally
for you guys to freak the [ __ ] out
because you couldn't post the acai bowl
that you were having this morning
you [ __ ] loser
you [ __ ] sheepseky loser like you
know why you're a loser because
you're a [ __ ] loser
just
i mean
there's just so much to do there's so
much other things to do like what how
were you spending your your days and it
made me weird feel weird because it
wasn't like oh [ __ ] instagram is down
and they were like i'll just go do
something else it was what the [ __ ] am i
going to do yeah what do i do instead of
doing something else like what the [ __ ]
am i gonna do i can't watch another
white person make boopky
i can't what am i supposed to do here i
can't watch somebody do a backflip off a
wall like yeah i i don't understand it
like the conspiracy part of me just
wants to think that they're just like
facebook instagram shills trying to be
like it's such a big deal that it's down
but uh but it's for real like the
regular ass people's lives crumble
because instagram that's the weird thing
i think that's the word though it
crumbled yeah why did it crumble for you
even if you did make a living off of
brand deals three four hours didn't
affect your livelihood at all it's not
like instagram was never gonna come back
up it's not like the people paying for
those brands were they were freaking out
just as much as you were you know like
but it's
your life goes on it goes down it could
be part of our social media generation
exaggerating exactly how much we feel
maybe about it right yeah like oh my god
i literally died how are you [ __ ]
talking to me right now yeah you
literally died and then the moment that
you it went back up you went straight to
twitter and instagram to tell people how
crazy you felt that it wasn't there yeah
it's a reflection on you it's not just
an app anymore it's an integral part of
your life that if you don't have it you
cannot exist which is so
sad right and no matter how many times
people say this or talk about it it's
just it's now a part of our society it
is who you are now it is an identity
thing now i've i've posted one photo in
the last four months
right yeah and
i used to be that guy that posted
multiple times a day yeah you know back
when it first started and then i started
seeing it like oh like social media is
like video games
you know it's like if um i don't play
like rpgs online but then some of those
games are like actual entire worlds on
their own right yeah own little
universes oh that's right right but
social media in itself is also a giant
universe of its own
right and so is the world exploding yeah
it's that world exploring not the
world
right so i get it though but those are
people investing their
entire lives or their brains and their
thought processes into that second life
trust me it's your second life it's not
your life here in our reality reality
looking at each other interacting with
it working breathing eating leaving
sleeping right
for some reason some people get lost in
their social media like that is their
life when i watch that chappelle special
and he says something so profound it was
very simple right and i'm pretty sure
many people have said this before but he
just goes don't give a [ __ ] twitter's
not real
he's like oh [ __ ]
big facts yeah it's not real and people
think that everything that on twitter is
real yeah it's not like a small percent
of the population actually uses social
media in that type of way right most
people don't well we forget like twitter
facebook and all that [ __ ] for me
in my memory everything all the social
media got huge in 2007
right that was
like
that around that time was when i
remember everybody was getting on
facebook everybody was getting on this
and that social media or whatever
but think about how old kids are these
days from that time they've only known
life with social media
i don't think there seems to be a lot of
people who forget that there was a life
without it yeah before i i like what one
of mariel's cousin does their kids
aren't allowed to use social media
whatsoever yeah and the way that they
interact and speak to people is insane
like they don't care about what's going
on about it and they're like like you'll
mention to them about other they're like
i don't know what that is like i'm gonna
play this game i'm gonna go outside yeah
you know which is very nice like
it's very refreshing to see so it's it's
possible to
to
raise kids without having them look at
those social media apps for validation
right
and it's going to be harder and harder
for these kids obviously when they're
the odd person out where they're like oh
i don't really care you know because
people are going to want to fit in when
you're young fitting in is a huge reason
to why you even do anything at all right
while you say the things that you do
while you pick up certain slang with the
music that you type that you listen to
has to do with everybody else like what
you
yeah
especially what you don't say right yeah
it's just a weird space to be in men and
i
like watching how everybody freaked out
about them made me kind of sad and um
yeah i mean but that's how like look i
i'm not an influencer i'm your friend
and i get to be on this podcast right
but that came with a lot of your
followers um coming through and looking
through my
my social media and then defining me
through that right and that that was it
felt just like people defining me for be
the fat guy yeah people defining me for
being the video guy or having some kind
of identification for me
and it made me realize that other people
play the game of social media
like it's their representation it's
their best foot forward yeah that's why
i don't have a problem posting the worst
aspects of myself yeah that's why i have
all those shitty [ __ ] videos from all
the [ __ ] that happened at my store
right
those are tragedies man like that
[ __ ] sucked when it happened to me as
it happened
but
in the way i was gonna play the game of
life and
how it was represented in social media i
was hurt by this i was [ __ ] angry by
this but you know what
you guys laugh at it that will make me
feel better
right and that's why i wasn't afraid to
show the worst aspects of my life
because first people [ __ ] laugh at it
yeah you know and that's the best way i
can accept it it's comedy too yeah it's
part of comedy it's part of
having to deal through these things but
then i'm not gonna be out there only
posting like a six-pack that i don't
have anymore yeah
it's it's you know because it comes and
goes i always hear this conversation too
where i know people who go oh i post
videos because i do it for myself right
and i always wonder too it's like okay
cool so nobody watches your videos you
still posting you still shooting all
this content yeah yes or no probably not
yeah you know that's okay that's 100
okay but you have to be honest with
yourself too you know you don't have to
justify what you're doing by trying to
sound like you're cooler than everybody
else i know why you're doing this
because you like the attention in order
to be an entertainer you have to like
attention to us to a certain extent it's
almost damn near impossible not to yeah
that's and that's what people might not
realize about social media that you're
entertaining other people
it's not real you're trying to be an
entertainer but it's not real
it's not real at all
that that's the hard part too it's how
do i explain to you people do a very
good job of saying i know it's not real
but the way that you behave says
otherwise right
the way it eats at their soul a hundred
percent and you know even for me too
there's comments that get at me but then
i always remind myself whatever you know
like what i was saying when when i was
we went in on this uh girl who was being
a [ __ ] racist
and then her fans were
hounding me on my my instagram right
yeah saying [ __ ] like i'm [ __ ] made and
i'm like i'm the perfect example of a
future domestic abuser or some [ __ ] then
i go look at their instagram and they're
like look at check out my new pokemon
cards
look at my xbox collection like shut
that [ __ ] up i get it whatever yeah like
i'm not worried about you i [ __ ] get
it yeah you know what's so hilarious to
the person that we're talking about this
person's family member hit me up
yeah and they were like
this person's a psychopath
like
and i kind of like did a little quick
looks like this person could just be
saying stuff and this person was a
family member and
that person that we're talking about
is ostracized from the family because of
their erratic behavior and how they
treat their family members
like they're nuts insane and i'm like
holy [ __ ] so her followers are her new
family yeah and so um this person was
telling me like everything that you said
about her is kind of crazy how spot-on
it is like you don't even know her but
what you observed is what we've been
dealing with for years she's been
torturing our family for [ __ ] years
people like that are so easy to read
yeah like a [ __ ] book yeah it's easy
you could just look at this person
because we've seen people like this a
million times over yeah and it's it's
when you like i said you see the guy who
has the pokemon card collection which
i'm not knocking on i love pokemon
right but you know it's just an example
for him to come at me like he's a hard
man yeah like i'ma beat you up bro you
just lucky my charizard don't got chains
on it right now
he [ __ ] throws something
yeah
once again social media is not real i
know so many couples who
are very good at pretending like they're
the most perfect couple but i know how
[ __ ] their [ __ ] marriage is i have to
deal with it all the time i got to be
the worst yeah
none of my friends that you know by the
way you idiots
but that's got to be so [ __ ] crazy
because i don't feel comfortable about
putting out an image of myself you know
that's
not a full representation of me but like
to keep posting that you're perfect
you're awesome all the [ __ ] time not
only that you're you're [ __ ] perfect
with this couple that's gotta be the
craziest lie i've ever seen yeah you
know it's psychotic how do you do that
how do you hate this person
and hate being around them wake up to
them wondering why the [ __ ] you're with
him and the next post is i'm so blessed
to be with jonathan it's [ __ ] amazing
every day is like a dream right so it
doesn't make sense when all of a sudden
all those couple photos are deleted and
they broke up and then there's a post
about uh closing to the chapter but what
about how awesome he was yeah
what happened there yeah you're just you
weren't keeping it real with yes people
i do i get dms now asking if me and
mariel are still together it's like
because i don't post her every day
[Laughter]
you have to be reminded that she exists
yeah let me tell you something i let her
know how awesome she is all the time i
call her stupid every day
this is what i mean like people need
this affirmation from strangers yeah you
know
i don't need you guys to tell me how
healthy my relationship is dude my
relationship is [ __ ] great you could
ask all my personal friends how how
fun it is to be around us
we have the time of our lives every
[ __ ] day i don't need to tell you
guys that and i don't need to show it
either i literally don't have to i have
nothing to prove and i think the reason
why you know our relationship has been
so strong is because we've been dealing
with our problems by ourselves
with
you know talking to each other about it
fighting through it without having to
show people that we're great i don't
need to show you that our relationship
is awesome especially with the times
when it's not yeah i don't need it i
just need to make sure that she's okay
and i'm okay and our relationship has
been great it's awesome i would love to
see this uh one social media account
where it's just fighting couples
fighting
you know i i have seen uh like a couple
accounts like there's a korean account
where
this couple the way they talk to each
other is so
[ __ ] like they're just screaming and
yelling all the time but then it's like
you see over time like oh this is like
endearing
but it's so real korean relationship for
sure dude yeah
i hate you you're so [ __ ] annoying
what did i say about that yeah like
crazy [ __ ] like that
yeah
just if they were keeping it real and i
saw some people fighting too then i
could follow
you know some of that [ __ ] like and be
like oh okay like it would help me as a
single guy to understand what
relationships
are
like totally about encompassing about
not just the perfect part of it yeah
because i've seen people like you know
my tongue is telling me about their girl
problems and it's like
oh cause she's so
like invested in all these k dramas she
thinks that a guy should do this do this
do that like go to the airport before
she leaves with a [ __ ] like huge
bouquet of roses [ __ ] those guys dude
she's like why do you have pores in your
face
yeah huh you don't love me enough to
close those [ __ ] pores
people
stop living in a reality because of it
it's like
what if we took away all the sugar
coating and all the glamour and like you
accept how shitty things are to the bad
parts of it but be able to laugh and and
work through all the [ __ ] shitty
parts of it that's [ __ ] health not
ignoring it i think the weird part too
is when i see
um
some people treat their significant
other very well based on how people
complement
how awesome their relationship is
they'll go oh you guys are
so awesome i love how like you guys look
so good together and they'll look at
each other they go oh like yeah you know
what you're the best babe because of the
comment and then it disappears 10
minutes later and they start fighting
all over again it's like do you only
felt good because somebody said you were
awesome like they're working their
relationship out through algorithms yeah
oh my god it's like also true you know
that time i surprise you with chocolates
a lot of people like that so um i guess
next time i should bring surprise her
with like a big box of [ __ ] kitkats
oh [ __ ] make a really shitty jason chen
reel
[Laughter]
i'm [ __ ] with you jason i love you
they're doing great by the way i'm not
using them as an example i'm just i just
hate his videos
yeah his [ __ ] videos that he it's not
even his original idea
he takes
like i know who i remember when i saw
his videos i think where did i see this
before he's [ __ ] he copies ishing she's
like she's a korean actress it's all the
videos i'm like you [ __ ] that's the
most chinese [ __ ] you could do jason
make a knock off
like even your [ __ ] instagram's a
knockoff dude
you did [ __ ] comedy covers yeah i
know you do that with your music don't
do that when [ __ ] comedy you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
god damn it dude he's funny because
other people are funny
you five foot two [ __ ] i love you to
death bro i [ __ ] love that guy he
makes me laugh he's one of like the most
honest dudes you'll ever meet by the way
i think he's like slightly autistic
people like asperger's or some [ __ ]
that's the best he's like
oh what's wrong with what i said yeah
he's like that's that's the [ __ ] mess
dude jesus said we'll say some you'll
never know the side of him because he's
a personal friend he'll say some
outlandish [ __ ] and everybody's like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about and
his face is just straight it's a matter
of fact
the [ __ ] best dude if you ever get to
be jason's friend you'll crack up 24 7.
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the jesus break podcast
oh i was gonna say one more thing about
uh squid game actually oh do you
remember
yes
halloween
it's gonna be all squid games
you're so [ __ ] funny because guess
what's in my cart right now and i
couldn't get any of the stuff in time
what because everybody's ordering all
the squid game outfits oh were you going
to get a tracks that was going to be the
kang dude
you'd get a snake i was getting a snake
tattoo it's all gone although
it's going to take like three weeks to
come in well i'm already i'm wearing my
squid game cosplay right now
i'm i'm ki hoon after he wins the game
that's why i'm growing up my [ __ ]
facial hair and this hair i'm just gonna
walk around and hold a bag of marbles
yeah
that's the easiest way to do it it's the
easiest way to be it dude [ __ ] guys well
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast i hope you guys enjoyed
that podcast for people out there who
are dealing with their weight issues and
their personal image i hope that gives
you a little bit of insight into that uh
you can follow ed at ed parkvp and you
could uh follow the genius brain podcast
every thursday and sundays all the way
up until january 1st after january 1st
is going to be once a week because i
have those three hour podcasts bro i got
more of those
we'll make them a little longer but i
got a few projects i'm opening up that
business out in hawaii um
i'm doing another podcast with tim so
we're gonna split it into that instead
so i got i got a lot of [ __ ] i have to
do i gotta get things i gotta get done
you know in the new year but we'll see
you all next time peace peace